>> Laura: DO YOU EVER FEEL
THAT THERE MIGHT BE ANOTHER
BATTLE PLAYING OUT JUST BENEATH
THE SURFACE OF THE ONES WE CAN
SEE AND HEAR, THE SPIRITUAL ONE,
I FEEL THAT WAY.
OSCAR-WINNING DIRECTOR WILLIAM
FRIEDKIN TERRIFIED THE NATION IN
THE 1973 WITH HIS FILM "THE
EXORCIST."
NOW HE IS EXPLORING THE REAL
THING.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND
ARROYO RECENTLY INTERVIEW THE
DIRECTOR ABOUT HIS NEW
DOCUMENTARY.
REMIND COME AND TELL US ABOUT
IT.
>> THE FILM IS CALLED "THE
DOLLAR             "THE DEVIL
AND FATHER AMORTH."
IN MANY WAYS, HE COMES FULL
CIRCLE MS PROJECT, WHICH
EXAMINES THE RITE OF EXORCISM.
HERE'S WHAT YOU CAN EXPECT FROM
THE FILM.
>> 500,000 ATTENDANCE SEE IN
EXORCIST EVERY YEAR.
HER NAME IS CHRISTINA.